we go from Hollywood to some movie
royalty and London and a shelter
nourished joining us right now with her
Bohemian Rhapsody exclusive hi Niecy so
are you a queen fan oh come on Nance a
million what about you oh yeah me too no
doubt okay well even you would be really
jealous because this was so cool I was
with the amazing cast as they lit up
London's famed Carnaby Street which was
all decorated in celebration of the
Queen biopic now I saw this movie and
let me tell you this is the kind of
movie that stays with you it really does
and especially for the man who played
Freddie Mercury himself
rami malek have you gotten him out of
your no I don't want to know if you had
Freddie Mercury in your system would you
ever want to Romney's transformation
into the late great frontman of queen is
uncanny but getting the gig wasn't so
hard you actually put yourself on tape
on an iPhone and sent in your audition
is that true I did yeah I did I mean
when you're presented with this
opportunity you just got to do anything
and if that means turning in the tape
within 24 hours you just do it Green's
Brian May and Roger Taylor our executive
music producers on Bohemian Rhapsody and
will closely with the cast you think
that stress them out but no what did
stress them having Freddie's sister
kashmira unset terrifying especially I
mean having Brian man Roger that
don't enough and then she will Susan
into sex and you know just kind of like
[Music]
well that's like 20 minutes of this film
felt like the concert was so amazing
you did that with Ryan Roger Roger yeah
I'm sitting there just so supportive you
know like they they were actually doing
the moves to radio gaagaa themselves
like actually like doing it like
cheering us on they were taking cell
phone videos like they were our fans it
was just so bizarre
no not bizarre I actually really get it
because Nancy when I was watching this
film with everybody else in the theater
we were also doing the radio Gaga I
could just see you doing that Niecy I
don't know I was
you gotta go see it again with me and
I'll do it with you okay oh I'm holding
you to that
okay
[Music]